today's topic
ready
yeah i don't believe our kelly's a
predator
shut it down we're good
yes he is next video
cool
i'm glad that we got that cleared out
yes yes he is i think he has an appetite
[Music]
are you serious it's gonna get good oh
yeah
oh no
i feel that r kelly pissed off the wrong
person
i don't know what he did but he pissed
off the wrong person it's a very very
good choice it works
you pissed off the wrong person
i think the big problem is that he
pissed on the wrong person
i think that's the problem i think he
pissed all the wrong person
i think that's the problem and that
launched this investigation
i am a little sympathetic to r kelly i
know that sounds really really crazy but
hear me out
i guess i need to start with what i've
done
ugh
let me just say this
if you guys are a fan of heart or if
this kind of stuff makes you
uncomfortable stop watching right now
it's about to get weird
when
i was doing my craigslist protocols hot
and heavy
i would get
a ton
i mean a ton
of
high school girls answering my ads
right now
but i know
she shows me eyes bro
say sorry some [ __ ] eyes
puts me
on
is
there
we're about to find out
civil damn
yeah stop
moxie [ __ ] up and typically
i ignored them
because even though i have a similar
appetite to r kelly
you know this is a youtuber with like
over 150 cases she's suits and nice all
right let's find out i like young women
but i don't like children
but this is how
a child tricked me bang no
bang no
this video keeps getting worse
this video keeps getting worse look look
this video is really disturbing
you need to put the second disclaimer
guys you need to put a disclaimer i've
cut out some parts that would make you
super queasy but i'm warning you there
may still be some portions here that'll
make you uneasy the original video
was
filthy
and i've seen some weird [ __ ] in my life
is it so on on the web
was when i downloaded it look at the
bottom left corner
this is how
a child tricked me
typically
they would be young
there would be lots of signs that this
girl was very very young
and i would just ignore him
then this one girl
she answered that
we started to talk
and she was an exceptionally mature
17 year old let me say this again
this chick was 17.
her conversation was different
she actually was a hairdresser
she was a hairdresser [ __ ] she made
braids
and oh my god she had these amazingly
firm
double dt
that should have been my clue
one of the things that i would do is i
would do social media research on all my
checks just out of curiosity
so i'm like doing my social media search
and i find her facebook page and i see
her with her high school friends
and i'm like
oh
[ __ ] so i call her up
and i ask her because you know she told
me she was 21 that's what she told me
and you cannot unfuck a chick you can't
unfuck her
and i was like i need you to tell me
something how old are you
and then she got very silent and she
said
i'll be 18 in four months
then she also said the age of consent in
georgia is 16 so you're good
she was everything that i liked it's 16
if you are
it's 16 if you are it depends 15 months
15 months so over it depends it depends
it depends some place is just like it's
full
some people it's a catch age yeah so
within three years whatever but
i don't know about georgia but just the
fact that you're a 30 old man and
talking to high schoolers is super
suspect but anyways i digress let's keep
going and you know what i kept doing i
kept [ __ ] her okay so i turn this up
what is that
this exact monster is like a p5
aye
she lied
to savage sailor no he knew because you
know what he said you can't unfuck a
girl at this point i [ __ ] her 15 times
the crime was done so i just kept
[ __ ] her from she was 17 to 22.
r kelly
and i are
similar but we're very different
because
i have
safeguards
i know when i'm getting out of control
you're getting out of control when you
post it on the web yeah you really don't
have safeguards the fact that you
thought it was a good idea to pose this
proves how stupid it is
but let's keep going
and this is how a lot of young girls end
up with older dudes their parents are
not heavily involved in their lives
where they have the time and the freedom
to get away with this stuff
and her parents
didn't check her she go out she spend
the night out her parents
were like you know she came home alive
cool
her parents were not on her so i didn't
have to worry about catching a charge
from the parents r kelly is being
portrayed as a
predator right did he hold a gun to
these women's heads no he put them in
[ __ ] dungeons and
held them hostage what are you smoking
what the [ __ ] is this guy on bruh
what are some of you on
r kelly is clearly guilty of what he did
any dude who hangs outside of high
schools to go pick up his next woman
when you a grown 30 old man is [ __ ]
weird to me
[ __ ] weird for you to just be hanging
around high schools waiting for these
girls to get off that sus bruh
even if it's not illegal in some places
it's [ __ ] strange and r kelly be on
hanging outside schools literally kept
some of these women in rooms and locked
them there and made them do stuff like
what are you [ __ ] smoking
and there is something
special
about
[ __ ] a chick who doesn't have a lot
of sexual experience because everything
you do to her is fun it's all brand new
and if you've got that type of appetite
it can be insatiable this is the reason
that i never got caught because i never
brought anyone
else into my circus so to speak you can
already tell that even though this guy
says
he did nothing wrong he uses words like
i never got caught
i didn't bring other people in on my gig
this is wild never be stopped so even in
your head you fee you understand
the implications of what it is that
you're doing you understand and even the
words that he uses it's like
you can tell that sex for him is not
very reciprocal he talks about appetite
in insatiable it's almost like gluttony
like you're consuming things
you know who does that a predator
yeah
remember when i started this video and i
told you i had all these high school
girls answering my craigslist ads
did i have a gun to their head
did i ask them to answer reply to my ads
they were searching this out
by that logic you could go ahead and
sell drugs to kids
hand it to a 15 year old 13 year old
10 year old they went and sought this
out
the reason why we don't allow these
young folks to seek it out because
generally we put a stop gap and we say
beyond this age you're not responsible
enough to make these decisions for
yourself now maybe you feel like there's
a bit of nuance maybe the age shouldn't
be 18 it should be 17 it should be 19.
who knows
but if your defense is
they are so i gave it to them
[ __ ] you're going to jail
can you imagine justifying some drugs to
kids by saying
i don't know i didn't have a gun today
what are you talking about
so this is why i have a problem with the
predator label because they were willing
participants
in the dynamic
essentially i conducted my [ __ ]
in the safe zone
i did stuff i knew i could get away with
so because you can get away with it it's
okay
you know what
for 20 plus years r kelly got away with
the two until he did it
i will tell you man you post this stuff
online don't be surprised if you get
some calls you bugging like there was
this one girl
and she was super cute
and then
i did my research on her and saw her
pictures of her with her mom and dad
which means her parents were very much
involved in her life
and that right there would have been the
danger zone
because
so you're seeking out
your predator
i am not a killer
but if i look at someone and i'm able to
puncture them
with my knife and the end of that they
didn't have to die
you're a killer so this is interesting
what is i like words
yes you do so
for parades to take advantage of exploit
or injure
so when he talks about these young women
not having their parents super in their
life he's seeing a vulnerability
and what he does is he understands
that's
the time to go when the parents are not
present they're vulnerable they are
malleable therefore they are accessible
and there's no danger to myself they are
vulnerable therefore he preys on them
right that's what it means to prey on
somebody that's what practice do right
they're higher up generally on the food
chain and they understand the other ones
are weaker and so they go for them you
are by definition of the word predator
and this is not even an age thing her
parents are not in her life she's
isolated from people i'ma slide right in
that's [ __ ] strange and he's just
trying to gaslight you into thinking
that he's not a predator
that's pretty much what it is fair
fair
because
this is how it happens
she comes over we [ __ ] she goes home her
mom and dad press her he's like i [ __ ]
this old man
and next thing you know mom and dad call
the police
police knocking at your door
that's how that goes down so i never put
myself in the crosshairs of the danger
zone you did now
you did now stupid
young
can be [ __ ] amazing i'm a nobody
i'm a nobody
that's why i was able to do this stuff
and get away with it because i'm a
nobody what's 9 plus 10 she's not 21.
you
stupid no i'm not you stupid
and let me tell you guys the original
video is way more foul he talks about
like taking some of these young women's
virginity as an old man he talks about
like smashing a mom and then having her
daughters after work like it's
disgusting 15 16 year olds like he goes
into some details i'll just like it's
very great it's like nasty and i edit it
out because it's a little bit too much
if you guys want to go find it i'm sure
you're going to be able to but good lord
that yeah
there are people like this out there
yeah and sometimes they're stupid enough
to out themselves but it comes with some
certain kind of you know you didn't get
caught so
now listen i'm not saying age
differences are inherently bad but if
you're hanging outside of high schools
guys you gotta start to ask yourself
questions
you gotta start to ask yourself some
if they're underage
gotta start asking yourself some
questions
that's weird and this man's got weird
intentions sorry but if you want to find
a young woman who doesn't have a good
relationship with her parents that's the
[ __ ] strangest [ __ ] i ever heard
that's nasty that's nasty well i'm
looking for a woman who's a drug addict
that's [ __ ] weird
yes
oh i'm looking for a guy who just got
out of a divorce really heartbroken
that's [ __ ] weird
you're looking for people when they're
at their lowest so you can [ __ ] with
them that's nasty yeah but there's
people like that out there oh yeah yes
and it's not even just sex it's also
scamming
people go after widowers all the time
with scams
people prey on vulnerable people in not
just sexual ways but in financial ways
and all kinds of ways
so
that's how people end up in a lot of
abusive situations they're isolated from
other people and then the wrong person
comes along and smells their
vulnerability and locks them in those
situations so
all this to say
be mindful folks like this um
and yeah like you heard them say man
parents be in your kids lives
be in your kids lives because people are
looking for parents that are not present
apparently you're you're kidding me
social media you your kids got social
media
uh be very mindful i'm not saying
micromanage that [ __ ] but be present you
heard it from the
the predator himself yeah
they're telling you this themselves so
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below
bro
the video is disgusting you think that's
nasty i'm telling you the original one
ten times i'm good i'm good yeah i'm
good yeah
nice
i'm gonna go take care of my appetite
let us know what you guys think
that's nasty